what's going on there reject nation
chucky episode four we are almost caught
up with the show hit that like button if
you haven't done so already slash it
like the chuckster subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
when our next check your reaction is up
as always full length watch the long
story sync with the timecode over at our
patreon page over there we cover a bunch
of shows with the same tier you get the
oshawa reaction highlights and watch
alongs included more than what's
featured in these thumbnails lastly
thank you nerd chronic for editing down
these highlights
i didn't accidentally thank the wrong
person initially let's see how this goes
[Music]
chucky did it
did he kill your dad too
holy [ __ ]
i mean
[ __ ]
you're you're not mad at him i know for
just like handing you a murderer
she's going to come after you again
why
because i told him to
oh oh
dude he knows i hate you perhaps
you freak
out you're so dead where are you going
look anyone who's told the truth about
chuck he's either been put away or worse
mostly worse it's just us
stay the hell away from me
you could have said something else bad
yeah
okay points for honesty but seriously
dude
do you have any idea what you've done
alexandra can you even grasp it told you
that your sister's in the icu a boy is
dead look none of this is my fault jake
jake
how can you torture that poor boy enough
oh chucky you brilliant mastermind
better to suffer the fire oliver this
has been so scary
hey did you do it
i'm not really supposed to
no one knows you but i cannot tell
anyone and i know you won't say anything
you got a spotify deal
my podcast's really taking off
she just doesn't know you like i do
see ya
see ya
if they don't end up together by the end
of this match
um how's how's junior
he's okay not okay but he has been under
a lot of pressure lately what's that
supposed to mean you put that much
stress on a kid sometimes he acts out he
won't [ __ ] you hey what's going on i
don't appreciate it is it the effort
[Laughter]
i'm like they've had some shits but
her kid's the one with that podcast what
i'm sorry but it's just a little
disturbing for a kid to be so obsessed
with crime excuse me yeah
the hell you say
you know to be considered to stay at
home bed you gotta actually parent your
kids posting your sonic a piece you can
relive your glory days it's not
parenting moment it's pathetic
[Music]
yeah
the medical examiner has determined the
cause of death
for oliver hayden
severe blood loss has a result of
multiple stab wounds oh my god
what
blame lexi it's her
junior you like cross country right
oh no
what you gotta do it cause you love it
otherwise you're not my son
you gotta do it cause you love being my
son
you'll be okay
we're buying you a new lung juju
you breathe better than you ever did
[Music]
hey
yeah yeah
more people
is everyone ready
weapon down and true yeah wait wait wait
do i need a sword don't worry i've got
it covered
there
come
our adventure is at hand yeah
[Music]
oh
man it's captain hook
we got him
[Music]
huh how could you get one little
companion yeah
[Music]
can i get one of those too now i feel
sorry
i
for
you i idea
[Music]
chucky's gonna be a giant dog
just a giant hand comes through them
[Laughter]
did you really
want me to die
did it really get that bad
oh my god did you you see your costume
how was i supposed to know how upset you
were well usually when you treat people
like [ __ ] they get upset but you didn't
just get upset
you wanted to kill me i wanted you to
die
but not because there's something wrong
with me
it says you [ __ ] deserved it
oh no no no no
oh
my
oh oh
yeah
yeah
just one less little vicious karen on
training we
then you can go break the news to junior
and everybody will get to see him cry
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
no
she wasn't that far if you could reach
everybody she could follow just like
crush it
oh bad
chucky
growth satisfy her the way junior
couldn't
and then be a dick to junior for the
rest of his life
why why would you think returning that
doll would be satisfactory it looks like
the toxic avenger now
kill the machine
take your candy
what's your deal lady
you got a charles leash spirit shard in
you
really living up to that stereotype
buddy
[Music]
how strange
from the minute i first saw you you know
i couldn't stand your [ __ ] face
maybe i'm just projecting
for another
cocktail let's make it a double
oh yeah
oh what a nightmare
wow
bleeding from the ears
wow what is in those
god i love hospitals
promise me that you won't tell a soul
[Music]
yep
what are you doing up
eddie caputo
go to sleep
that ain't familiar eddie caputo
code white resuscitation teams and d58
priority
one no
where's the dead body
yeah it's gotta be moved
or there's the dead body
oh my
[Music]
[Music]
oh
yeah
ouch man
[Music]
wow
oh man
that's chucky
i don't know who to root for
yes
because i love chucky so much
that i'm like
i care so much about jake
it's like when i'm in their perspective
i really
really care that they are not wrongfully
especially jake these are wrongfully
accused of murder and i i don't want him
to have anything pinned on him that he
didn't do
but then you cut the chucky and i'm like
but i don't want this guy to die
i'm going to stop i want to stop i want
that sick sadistic bastard to keep doing
what he's doing
hey you know i i feel like one maybe
doesn't exclude the other
i just want this to keep carrying on
absolutely yeah no i don't want it i
don't want the the promised end it's
that's that it's such a weird position
to be in because normally it's like it's
not even a villain you love to hate
you'll love him you just love him you
love him away man keep killing and then
it's just unfortunate when his
motivations clash with the other
characters that you care about
yeah it's the opposite of like slasher
movies yeah you know
yeah it's like i'm not necessarily
rooting for a lot of people to die but i
am rooting for chucky to kill yeah
that's the weird part i don't want
people to die but it's always awesome
when he does his thing and there are
sort of people i'm worried about if they
die yeah
yeah totally
oh man this is one of the best slasher
things i think i've ever seen um because
it captures this the spirit of it all
but
it's really tense i love the
messed up look of chucky they've looked
at them before of not not exactly that i
haven't done anything that's like exact
not exactly that i mean he's but they've
done like ditched uh
his head's like in a safe and you know
it's like ripped open like they've
really they've got some gross stuff yeah
they've they've mutilated chucky many
times
this is a just an addition to that yeah
yeah but it's it's a really icky and
cool look it really reminded me of the
toxic avenger
i loved how the first half of this he's
not in it at all yeah other than the
flashbacks which you start to see if
anything wait what you're seeing is why
he
why charles lee ray in particular
is
perfectly
tethered
for a doll
um in in this companionship role
of you see in the childhood in the prior
episode with the serial killer
it took a liking to him and then even as
growing up in an orphanage he did that
for someone else it's just like there's
a perfect role for him to be chucky from
what if anything that's what he
recreates
yeah
i mean it's it's funny because yeah they
do match really well because even him
taking that kid under his wing it's it
is kind of like the friends to the end
we're like the peter pan and the you
know and the lost boys and all that and
it you know it can be a very slippery
slope revealing too much backstory about
your character but i think it's been a
really nice addition to this show like
this show i think would be fun enough if
it was just all the present day stuff
but the behind the scenes and the
different or the you know flashbacks and
the different people they have playing
him at different ages like they are
creating like a nice
unified little origin well they the way
they handle this particular flashback
story they did kind of like a made for
tv special yeah you know yeah without
the kind of the the way the audio was
done and everything it so even though
they kept an eight millimeter it felt
like a made for tv special or some
program yeah something like a school
program public access tv or he has some
kind of like independently funded
cautionary picture yeah yeah which uh
which was amusing
gross with the maggots coming out of
that guy's throat
and and i like that this only pretty
much had two settings the hospital
setting and the
burnt house settings like abandoned
house setting but also i was really
impressed with the um
yeah halloween
uh i was really impressed with uh the
way they handled the way the
the
relationship started taking turns with
lexi and jake
i'm surprised her first thought wasn't
you knew
yeah it took a little bit of time to get
there
you put that in mine it was only at the
point where she where they reached the
idea that jake wanted him to kill her
then she started to object it was almost
like you knew this thing was alive and
you gave it to me whatever oh you wanted
it to kill me that's messed up
that conclusion a little earlier
for the most part i really liked their
stuff together but there are a couple
little threads like that of of like okay
i guess you're a little willing to
overlook certain aspects until we get
back to you which is i mean in character
for her to some extent but well i like
the blow up scene that he had when they
were at the house yeah uh when he's
going off of like i didn't want to kill
anybody i wanted to kill some i didn't
want to kill somebody i wanted to kill
you it's like i don't have a desire to
be a
killer just hate you i wanted you to die
yeah yeah
and
sometimes her naiveness just really
just really bothers me it's like god
damn i believe
i've only been exposed to minutes of
things you've done
there's not even everything that
happened before chucky enters this guy's
life of just how awful you've been to
him
and so i i can only imagine just how far
she's taking it and yeah and how many
other people she's done these things too
i mean i thought that if that was
interesting because it is a little bit
like you had no idea just how terrible i
might be feeling based on
yeah why didn't you talk to me but you
wanted to kill something must be wrong
like you're doing it right now it's like
you're doing it we almost kind of even
tried to talk when you sort of almost
tried to apologize to me but that look
how that went you were just laying
insults in there left and right even
still you just thought if you have a
proper apology maybe you don't want to
go on your hand man
but i love that chuck you let her live
because you start to see like oh this is
the real suffering right yeah
yeah like discredit you and make you
suffer and make you watch everyone you
love die like they didn't
clearly establish
he must have let her live directly
because he had an opportune time to
murder her he had the knife in the hands
and i'm
completely baffled
how
she wound up perfectly fine
yes without any smoke inhalation she was
in the room where it started
that's the one thing that is one one
aspect like she is a hundred percent
okay yeah
and uh but other people were like
even freaking junior has lung damage and
stuff but she's not hospitalized one bit
well she doesn't have to run track and
field so you know she was like trapped
in the room
yeah
there's there's no real proper excuse
for that and was attacked too it's so
it's so funny it's amusing but it just
goes to show that maybe chucky
ate it in some way of making sure she
lived
because i mean yeah i mean part of his
whole
the the the funny part about chuckie and
especially that's been honed in on
through the show i think is is yeah like
he's deranged and he'll kill you and all
that stuff but he'll also like kind of
on the fly come up with a web for you to
get tangled in that can then further
perpetuate his own sick pleasures yeah i
love it yeah absolutely
the show gets you going man even with
the mom investigating jake or just like
oh come on i'm only gonna not like you
but not because you're doing anything
wrong i know
you're just doing you're doing exactly
what you should be doing just stop
asking him questions oh thank god you
just found your partner's body over in
the other room where jake couldn't have
been did you pull them away yes alibi
yeah we don't have to talk about this
anymore except we probably will
and i think it's cool that devin became
like it makes sense that with what he's
naturally interested in and what his
podcast is that he would decide to look
some [ __ ] up yeah absolutely it's cool
that brought the three of them together
junior being left out sucker i like the
clash of the parents too yeah i mean you
gotta understand guys sometimes there's
scenes not featured in our reaction
highlights just because
we have to cut it down
for the sake of being able to make this
public on youtube
uh so i don't know if the scene with
appearance is included in these
highlights yet but talking about it i i
it's that's such a credit to the show is
how they managed to just make all the
personal drama so effective to the point
where
that gets you tense
and you're not even thinking about guys
it's chucky's fault like you're just so
pulled into the immediate situation of
she's having an affair he's upset he
doesn't realize how much he pressures
junior into being a track star runner
and then they've got these parents
they've already had tension and
animosity with and other blaming each
other which only just makes sense and i
love how that's all just like collapsing
and falling apart absolutely i'm like
damn this drama is so good i'm so i'm so
into it it's better than most chucky
movies it's better than most slasher
movies
like it's so good and
just chucking coming out on top and just
giving the finger while everyone's in
the room
it's so good it's so great it's
fascinating to me because too and i mean
chucky has always to some degree had
this but especially watching the show
and like you know going through you know
the flashbacks and stuff like they
really do a nice job of
creating a weird duel like so many
slashers are at odds with being a sort
of you know grounded crime
whatever killing experience versus being
the supernatural unstoppable creature
and i love the way they paint charles
lee ray because the parts where you're
really honed in on him do feel like
you're watching something more akin to
like a henry portrait of a serial killer
or something where it's just about the
twisted human psyche and when you see
him in his youth you're like god this
sounds exactly like the story of just a
real life serial killer and then you
take
that little added bonus of the origin of
yeah he is just a serial killer then
transfers his soul and so you in weird
ways it's like as heightened and strange
as chucky is if you look at the series
overall and if you look at this show you
know it's like there's all the stuff
that's bonkers and yet you can still
really easily pull it back into
something that's like personal and
nuanced somehow yeah and intimate like
and that's the i think the true magic at
the core is like the chucky doll in any
situation is gonna create some kind of
eerie freaky whatever horror mumbo jumbo
and it's uh it's kind of special you
know because i don't know if every i'm
sure with good writers anything's
possible but i can't imagine a lot of
slasher movies fitting into a mold like
this as well as this is doing it and
yeah like making you feel for the
different victims and and yeah hate
certain people and then come back around
on them like i really
we talked in the last one about you know
like the kind of change with lexi about
not necessarily
rooting for her or loving her but
understanding her more to the point
where you don't necessarily like want to
see her die as much and now you know i
love the way they're building on that
you know i still don't know why she's
such a [ __ ] up human being
yeah i still know why she's such a [ __ ]
you know it's something something
parents is something something parental
neglect but even their villains seem
fine other than some comparisons to the
younger daughter i'm like that's
i don't know why she's so
so mean yeah yeah but even even still i
just i i
loved their scenes together in this
episode
yeah i really like the moment where she
puts her hand on as her running away
like i like the way you see the bond
forming with them without calling too
much attention to it but you know that
the second he saves her yeah is it
really telling that choice of i'm not a
killer like you when he had a chance to
kill her it's a perfect chance to kill
her and he says thanks for not letting
go yeah i thought it was a really
touching moment and then yeah i i i am
totally on board for like the three of
them teaming up yeah like [ __ ] lexi i'm
not at that point with her anymore yeah
yeah so sometimes she just says some
[ __ ] i'm just like damn you're so dumb
yeah
how do you die are you completely un
i i mean john said it's about like i've
had my experiences of being a bully
uh to be bullied i was just being
bullied
my experience is setting my evil dollar
and i knew exactly what i was doing
i was justified all right but john's had
his experiences too uh but i mean
every situation is unique upon itself
but she's a smart human being and i
don't know she just must be so in
complete denial yeah of every little
thing that she does wrong but then
sometimes she seems like she has like
an empathetic conscience and i'm like
why is this one element here of how you
treat him just so how are you so blind
to just how messed up you are yeah
absolutely just like it was that bad did
you really get that
are you nuts are you are you the
craziest one in the show what's going on
with you and it's funny because there
there are certain aspects that where i
feel like you could say well maybe they
should write her to be a little more
sharp but i think they do allow in the
back and forth between them like this
episode nicely allowed you
to kind of have the argument with them
where you see some of it from jake's
perspective and you see some of it
definitely from lexi's perspective and
you kind of see the mud that created
this harsh angry situation and because
it's through teens like it echoed in the
in the interrogation when she's like you
know was oliver bullying you just didn't
know what to do and you just needed it
to stop and i'm like that is kind of
what happened just not exactly as you're
pitching
this questioning here
but yeah no i like her i think she's a
great i think she's a great actress
though yeah and then and the mayor is
her actual mother in real life who's uh
yeah i remember reading that
who was the name eddie
eddie caputo
who is that that sounds familiar i don't
i i don't really remember the scenes
very well but i think he was a victim i
think we see him die at the hands of
charles lee ray in a preview in like the
first movie or something like that why
was his name dropped eddie caputo no why
was his name dropped here oh because she
scorned him and told him to go to bed
when he was like messing around with his
severed hand gift
she's the the yeah the orphanage
monsters
yeah yeah
so it's just an easter egg for fans
don't remember eddie caputo in that
first movie then
not like the name sounded familiar i was
like
but nope nothing's really coming to mind
yeah nothing vivid whatsoever i mean
because there i think that might be more
of i don't feel like that character was
like as significant as other characters
that were mentioned here like they
mentioned tiffany and they mentioned
nika who i mean tiffany
she's got to show up at some point
didn't chucky get some revenge in the
first one like when he was in charles
lee ray's body
maybe
that might be it
i'm trying
to remember i remember the first i don't
remember like certain scenes from the
first one and who died when and whose
name was which and yeah i have a memory
of being like chucky's pov as he's like
running after someone who's not related
to like andy or the people and i'm like
wait a minute was that it um
yeah you saw jennifer tilly yeah but i'd
be curious i mean
they're playing it it's i think it's
good because if you haven't seen
anything and you don't know really to
expect that there might be multiple
chuckies it's good because it plays like
is he running around the hospital is
this like a hallucination people are
having but i wouldn't be surprised if
there becomes an element where a tiffany
or anika come in and add more chuckies
more charles lee ray bits to the puzzle
that'd be fun but i kind of like it
where it's just isolated i do too i i'm
not against the idea because i've seen
it work in the past in certain
in movie context but right now yeah i
agree i'm very much enjoying just jake
and his chucky he keeps it personal yeah
absolutely
um especially when you're doing your
first show chucky instead of making it
chuckies
season
season three even more chuckies
all right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below one more to go then we're
caught up with the show
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button and then there's hawkeye that
comes out to make sure to throw our
whole schedule off yes awesome midnight
gene jeter there was a patron on our
patreon eject list who i would want to
have a possessed doll of it would be you
because i know hey you're not gonna
murder me but you'd probably do a lot of
strange and esoteric things that then i
would have to awkwardly explain away and
create my own alibis for this alienating
myself from my friends and family maybe
even getting me in trouble with the law
although hey
two you could use your creativity in
that form and then you know i could take
the credit you know we could build some
kind of massive empire make like you
know a benevolent creative chucky-like
team
or you could just you know kill me for
even having the thought but gene either
way you're one of the most animated and
interesting people at our patreon and i
don't ever want you to stop doing what
you do
much love and stay pledged buddy
[Music]
you